it's pinewild est ce qu'un jour on se
lassera de ce format c'est une vraie
question
moi-même j'adore continu et que vous
même vous adorez regarder mais jusqu'où
cette relation va nous mener finalement
quoi les histoires sont moins chiante
que moi rassurez vous les amis c'est
parti pour trois histoires vraies trois
témoignages finalement et on commence
avec celui de lisa visa explique que
l'histoire qu'elle raconte s'est passé
lorsqu'elle était encore à la fac elle a
vécu à l'iss la vista la communauté
étudiante de l'ue csb connue pour être
une école de gros fêtard et vous avez
des fois dans les campus à l'université
ça fait beaucoup la fête et d'une école
à l'autre ça fait plus ou moins la fête
là on est le curseur il est très haut
cette nuit-là lisa elles rentrent à 2h30
du matin après avoir bu quelques verres
rien d'excessif
elle explique qu'elle vit dans une
maison avec deux copines à elles elles
sont donc en colocation elle explique
donc qu'il était fréquent que l'une
d'entre elles ramènent une ou plusieurs
personnes à l'appart est que cette ou
ces personnes dorment et soit sur les
meubles soit dans leur lit selon les
affinités bref juste des meufs qui ont
la vingtaine qui flavie a rien d'anormal
cette nuit là pendant que lisa était
parti boire un verre à l'extérieur ses
deux copines colocataires ont invité
quelques personnes à l'appart pour faire
une mini fête et ses quelques personnes
lisa ne les connaissez pas s'était passé
m en rentrant chez elle lisa constate
donc que l'une de ces personnes est
resté dormir là et qu'elle dort sur le
canapé dans le salon elle explique
qu'elle n'a pas allumé la lumière parce
qu'elle a vu une ombre sur le canapé
qu'elle voulait pas réveiller la
personne mais qui avait bel et bien une
personne sur le canal en allant vers sa
chambre elle se rapproche donc du canapé
elle s'aperçoit que la silhouette est
très raide que la personne dégage un
truc bizarre
sykes des fois on a su ning on se dit
attends il ya un truc pas normal la
balle à lisa hélas feeling lisa elle
donc à l'arrêt en train de regarder
cette personne est cette personne d'un
qui tourne la tête vers lisa et truc un
peu bas dans cette personne regarde les
a droit dans les yeux avec des yeux
grands ouverts
elle dormait pas du tout elle va penser
que cette personne est probablement soit
ivre soit sous drogue
bref n'importe quoi qui puisse expliquer
qu'une personne se retourne brusquement
vers toi à 2h30 du matin avec des yeux
grands ouverts elle rejoint sa chambre
comme prévu et elle prend bien soin de
verrouiller la porte de la chambre avant
de se glisser dans son lit hélas elle
s'endort tout va bien qui finit bien pas
du tout à 4h30 ya un bruit étrange près
de la porte de sa chambre qui la
réveille un bruit qu'elle décrit comme
le bruit que pourrait faire quelqu'un en
tapotant des doigts contre une porte
premier réflexe assez logique lisa elle
reste dans son lit elle bouge pas et
elle fait aucun bruit
bref elle attend que ça passe comme on
le fait tous dans ces situations où il
ya un truc très bas dans et on est dans
le déni
jusqu'au moment où on se rend compte que
bas il va peut-être falloir agir parce
qu'un truc pas normal les minutes
passent et le bruit devient de plus en
plus fort comme si la personne cette
fois tapé contre la porte en bois avec
les doigts de ses deux mains
pas une activité commune de taper avec
ses doigts contre les portes donc l'ipad
en faisant le moins de bruit possible
elle prend son téléphone et elle envoie
un message à sa coloc qui est de l'autre
côté de l'appartement
elle lui explique que son ami est en
train de frapper compte sa porte avec
ses doigts que ça la fait bien bas des
élus demandent d'aller lui parler pour
le calmer parce que ça l'empêchent de
dormir
après plusieurs minutes d'attenté lisa
reçoit aucune réponse de sa pote tout
simplement parce qu'elle adore
elle est donc seul dans sa chambre et il
ya un gars de l'autre côté de sa porte
qu'elle ne connaît pas avec un train de
gratter depuis de nombreuses minutes
avec ses doigts contre le bois de la
porte
horrible situation lisa on voit donc un
message à sa deuxième colocataire et
malheureusement pareil
pas de réponse probablement parce
qu'elle dort aussi sauf que l'inconnu de
l'autre côté de la porte il va plus se
contenter de gratter à la porte cette
fois il va attraper la poignée et ils
valent à sucre et dans tous les sens
pour ouvrir la porte
comme la situation s'aggravait qu'elle a
aucune réponse lisa elle décide quitte à
faire plus de bruit tant pis d'appeler
l'une de ses deux colocataires sa coloc
cette fois décroche et les à lui dit ton
pote il est fou est ce que tu peux faire
quelque chose parce que là il en train
de 21 à porte et c'est vraiment chiant
et après quelques secondes de silence sa
colocataire lui répond cannes potes il
n'y avait pas de gars qui dormait sur le
canapé personne est resté dormir à la
maison
l'adrénaline de lisa monte en flèche et
à ce moment là elle se rend compte aussi
que ça fait plusieurs minutes que plus
personne ne gratte à sa porte et donc
elle se demande où est passé ce [ __ ]
de type est quasiment au même moment
elle entend un bruit sourd suivi d'un
hurlement de peur et à ce moment-là lisa
décide d'appeler les flics parce que la
situation dégénère
elle explique la situation aux policiers
et ils lui disent qu'ils envoient tout
de suite de voitures tout la partie se
retrouve plongé dans le silence et c'est
là que lisa baisse les yeux et elle voit
que le mec vient de glisser ses doigts
entre le sol et le bas de la porte
lisa face aux doigts qui dépassent de sa
porte elle n'arrive plus à se contenir
et elle hurle tout en reculant
elle explique d'ailleurs qu'elle s'en
veut et que c'est son plus grand regret
parce qu'en fait elle avait juste a
écrasé les doigts du gard pour peut-être
le faire fuir
bref malheureusement pour les as le gars
s'est barré juste avant que la police
arrive
les policiers n'ont pas retrouvé ce gars
est du coup ils s'étaient infiltrés dans
la maison en passant par la porte
latérale en verre et en crochetant la
serrure
lisa explique que le pire dans
l'histoire c'est qu'elle a regardé ce
mec droit dans les yeux en rentrant chez
elle et que sur le moment elle n'a pas
compris mais en fait s'il était tout
raide et immobile comme ça c'est pas
parce qu'il dormait mais c'est parce
qu'il essayait de se cacher dans le noir
sauf que lisa à la clairement vu et
c'est pour ça que le gars s'est retourné
vers lisa en mode est-ce que je suis
foutu je vais devoir agir là
ce n'est pas du tout un ami de ses
colocataires qui dormait en fait c'est
juste un intrus qui se cachait c'est pas
pareil quand même voilà alors c'est
marrant ça me fait un peu penser à
l'histoire calice avait raconté quand il
était venu dans la vidéo serait de voir
avec gas mais un peu remis le sait quoi
il faut arrêter les gens de s'infiltrer
chez déchets d'autres gens en pleine
nuit là comme ça il faut il faut arrêter
ça bon il est temps de passer la
deuxième histoire qui d'ailleurs est
liée au verrouillage de porte
oui laissez moi vous raconter l'histoire
de francis alors francis donc il est
obsédé par le verrouillage de porte vous
savez ces fameux toque ou tu vérifies
tout le temps que la porte est fermée et
tu oublies très très rarement de la
ferme est tellement tu est obsédé par ça
il explique qu'il a d'ailleurs un petit
rituel depuis plusieurs années c'est
qu'avant de dormir il vérifie que toutes
les portes de la maison sont bien
fermées à clé cinq mois avant les faits
francis emménage avec sa femme et ses
deux enfants dans une nouvelle maison
il explique que c'est une maison qui est
vraiment très excentré elle est très
très loin des grandes voix proche par
conséquent il n'y a jamais de piétons
autour de chez lui puisque bah voila
c'est une route privée qui mène que à sa
maison dont personne n'a rien à faire le
détail important il n'aime pas dormir
dans le noir francis il est toujours une
lumière allumée quelque part dans la
maison qui fait un petit halo sous sa
porte ça le rassure toi comme moi que
même ceux qui aiment la ruralité
ce sera sur d'une manière ou d'une autre
bref à moins après l'aménagement francis
se retrouve enfermé à l'extérieur de
chez lui parce qu'il est sorti il a
claqué la porte il a oublié ses clés
classique chic qui nous est tous arrivé
du coup ils essaient de passer par la
porte arrière de sa maison sauf que bat
avec son [ __ ] de toc il l'avait fermée
à double tour malheureusement il a
hésité à l'ouvrir au pied de biche
sauf que la porte étant dans un état
nickel ça lui faisait mal au coeur donc
il a préféré appeler le propriétaire et
lui demander de venir ouvrir la porte
avec le double des clés quitte à devoir
attendre plusieurs heures
bref un peu plus d'une semaine plus tard
c'est là qu'ils commencent à se passer
des trucs bizarres chez francis francis
se réveille en pleine nuit parce qu'ils
la méga soif et il se dirige la tête
dans le cul vers sa cuisine en ouvrant
la porte de sa chambre il ya un détail
qu'il le fait chier c'est que toutes les
lumières sont éteintes
sauf que souvenez-vous francis il laisse
toujours une lumière allumée il va
d'abord penser que c'est une panne de
courant avant de se rendre compte qu'en
fait il l'entend le ventilateur de sa
chambre qu'elle jugerait à lui et que
donc c'est pas une panne de courant
francis fait un pas pour sortir de sa
chambre il se trouve dans le couloir et
leïla des frissons il a le sentiment
d'être observés et son instinct lui dit
que cette personne se trouve sur sa
gauche
francis tourner la tête et y'a personne
en revanche il voit les étoiles là où
ils devraient juste y avoir de
l'obscurité tout simplement parce que la
porte arrière de chez lui est grande
ouverte
francis il a la conviction qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est au bout
près de la porte cachée dans l'ombre qui
attend qu'il soit assez près de la porte
pour l'attraper et le fracasse il
réalise alors qu'il est un peu
responsable de la sécurité de sa famille
c'est l'homme de la maison quoi il prend
alors son courage à deux mains et il
marche en direction de la porte pour la
fermer francis tend la main vers la
poignée de la porte et après plusieurs
tâtonnements provoqué par la panique il
réussi à choper la poignée et a claqué
la porte
le lendemain francis demande donc à ses
enfants et à sa femme si c'est eux qui
ont ouvert la porte
évidemment ils lui disent que non et
leur demandent aussi si quelqu'un est un
la lumière dans la nuit et évidemment
ils lui répondent que non
pendant trois semaines francis va
vérifier régulièrement le verrou de la
porte arrière et il est toujours bien
enclenchée y a rien d'anormal qui se
passe jusqu'à une nouvelle nuit où
francis se réveille d'un énorme
cauchemar puis il va dans sa cuisine
pour boire quelque chose elle a une
nouvelle fois il est frappé par le même
sentiment que trois semaines avant il a
l'impression que quelqu'un de regarde
ses yeux se dirige naturellement vers la
porte arrière de la maison et mauvaises
surprises
elle est grande ouverte comme trois
semaines avant francis licite de
s'élancer vers la porte pour la fermer
sauf que cette fois il est convaincu
qu'elle s'est pas ouvert tout seul il va
finir par s'endormir de nouveau pour se
réveiller deux heures plus tard parce
que c'est le matin qui doit aller au
travail et après cette levée et avoir
pris la direction de la chambre de ses
enfants pour les réveiller ses yeux se
tournent naturellement vers la porte
arrière et une fois de plus elle est
ouverte et il constate qu'à l'extrémité
de la porte il ya des rayures et des
plis et là francis se dit bon il faut
que j'arrête de prendre ça à la légère
on va se poser on va réfléchir à ce
sujet tout d'abord il se demande si le
jour où il s'est retrouvé enfermé en
dehors de chez lui il a bien vu la porte
en fait rire mais tout simplement en
cause les réduire et les plis qui sont
apparues entre temps peut-être qu'en
fait ils étaient là dès le début et qui
les avait juste pas vu mais il va quand
même faire quelque chose avec cette
porte donc il voulait au début m des
nouveaux verrous sauf qu'eux ne trouvant
pas sa perceuse et s'est rabattu sur des
clochettes qui l'a attaché à la poignée
de la porte du côté intérieur du côté de
chez lui bref ça va arriver une dernière
fois avant qui change définitivement les
serrures cette nuit là francis se couche
tôt il se réveille aux alentours de 3
heures il va vérifier la porte parce
qu'il a une obsession maintenant avec
cette porte à juste titre et cette fois
bonne surprise la porte est fermée
il retourne se coucher et cette fois il
fait un cauchemar à cauchemars horrible
dans lequel il entend les clochettes de
noël qui l'a mis à la poignée alors il
se lève et en s'approchant de la porte
il tombe sur une petite fille de dos
étant donné qu'il est dans un cauchemar
il a étrangement pas peur du tout de
cette petite fille et lui demande son
nom
sauf que la petite réponse
quelqu'un arrive quelqu'un arrive
quelqu'un arrive et elle va crescendo
comme ça crée de plus en plus forts
quelqu'un arrive jusqu'à se retourner
la mâchoire sur la poitrine la bouche
anormalement large en criant quelqu'un
est ici francis se réveille en sueur is
love et bien évidemment la lumière de la
cuisine est éteint et la porte arrière
est grande ouverte
une nouvelle fois francis ferme la porte
et il constate que les clochettes ne
sont plus sur la poignée
il s'aperçoit qu'elles sont posés sur un
meuble dans le couloir ce matin là il va
poser des questions à ses deux enfants
et à sa femme
sans trop en dire pour pas les effrayer
de ce qui se passe il va juste leur
demander s'ils ont entendu quoi que ce
soit d'anormal cette nuit son fils de 13
ans lui dit que n'en rien mais que si à
2h30 il s'est levé pour aller aux
toilettes et il a vu que la porte
arrière était grande ouverte et il est
donc allé la fermer francis lui demande
alors si les clochettes été sur la
poignée ou pas et son fils lui dit qu'il
est quasi sûr que oui et cette fois
enfin francis des partis dans un magasin
pour acheter une perceuse ainsi qu'une
nouvelle serrure et il a passé
l'après-midi du coup à bricoler sa porte
et a changé la serrure et rajouter même
des vo au moment où il nous raconte
cette histoire il explique que malgré ça
quelques jours avant de la raconter
il a remarqué des nouvelles rigueur et
les nouveaux clips sur sa porte
sauf que cette fois les vieux loups
n'ont pas cédé donc elle s'est pas
ouverte ce qui ouvre dans cette histoire
c'est que c'est évident qu'il est en
danger
c'est évident qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est
pas très bien intentionné mais comme il
n'ya pas de répercussions graves
personne s'est fait agresser rien n'a
été volé il ya aucune trace d'intrusion
que dalle francis il va attendre
tellement longtemps avant d'agir je
trouve ça dingue
en fait je trouve ça hyper intéressant
comme certaines fois les gens sont dans
la non réaction et sont totalement dans
le déni de la gravité de la situation
dès qu'il a vu les traces de rayures
fallait changer la porte voire même
déménagé directement je trouve ça fou
tout ça nous amène à la troisième
histoire celle de gabriel gabriel qui
fait une activité que j'aurais jamais le
courage de faire à cas le trailer vous
savez il ya des parcours énorme et les
gens vont faire ces parcours marché des
distances assez énorme
en auto survie donc c'est à dire ils y
vont avec leur tante avec leur
bouilloire il prévoit assez d'eau et de
vivres pour voir finir le parcours et ça
dure plusieurs jours bref gabriel il
part avec sa copine et l'essai de faire
le sud du sentier de virginie c'est un
sentier qui fait environ 260 km de long
et qui traverse les forêts nationales de
george washington et jefferson il
explique que la partie sud de sentiers
et la moins fréquente et la plus reculée
exactement ce qu'ils recherchent avec sa
copine
en gros ils vont là bas parce que ils
veulent pas croisé d'autres gens ils ont
vraiment envie d'avoir la sensation
d'être seul s'excusait faisait des ou
enfin et encore comme francis la fois
arrêter
bref on est début août
ob ils se rendent là bas ils sont
contents l'air et assez doux on a le
changement de couleur des feuilles parce
qu'il ya changement de saison le temps
est parfait il ya des paysages
magnifiques tout se passe
merveilleusement bien sauf les deux
dernières nuits sur ce sentier était
censé camper soit sur le sentier soit
dans un refuge désigné donc tous les x
km et une sorte de refuge qui est un
point de ralliement des gens qui font
ces parcours dans lequel tu peux te pose
mais comme dit gabriel et sa copine ils
n'ont pas envie de croiser d'autres gens
ils ont pas envie en plein milieu de la
nuit que quelqu'un vienne leur demander
leur gloire ou des conneries ils veulent
vraiment être en autonomie totale donc
ils vont trouver leur propre petit coin
en hors piste ça sent l'embrouillé au
milieu d'une petite clairière se trouve
l'endroit parfait pour gabriel et sa
copine endroit dans lequel ils décident
d'installer leur camp et montrent leurs
tentes
et puis se glisse dans leur sac de
couchage et se dirige vers une belle
nuit de sommeil sauf que vers 2 heures
du matin la porte arrière de la maison
de gabriel est ouverte
pas du tout vers 2 heures du matin
gabriel est réveillé par sa copine qui
lui dit prends ton arme il ya quelqu'un
dehors qui marche autour de notre tente
c'est bon pour vous cette phrase guerre
elle explique que lors de ces randonnées
il emmène tout le temps m1911 avec lui
qui est un pistolet il expliquant sait
jamais trop sur quoi on va tomber et que
donc il a l'habitude d'emmener un
flingue avec lui bref il a sorti le
flingue de son sac avant de s'asseoir et
d'écouté soigneusement tout ce qui
pouvait se passer autour de la tente
pendant plusieurs minutes
aucun bruit spécifique avant qu'ils
entendent des bruits de pas sur des
brindilles
d'après le bruit des pas il explique que
selon lui c'est un bipède qui marche
gabriel prend sa lampe de poche et sort
de la tente ils se décident alors inondé
de lumière la zone d'où provenaient les
par gabriel pense avoir vu quelqu'un
bouge et derrière un arbre il se met
alors à lui crier dessus en lui disant
de se casser n'ayant pas de réponse
gabriel continue d'éclairer l'endroit
d'où provenaient les pas tout en
pointant avec son arme et en avançant là
bas en s'approchant de la zone il entend
de nouveau des bruits de pas qui cette
fois proviennent de sa droite
il a donc deux solutions soit ils
décident de pourchasser la personne qui
était là
soit il retourne dans la tente dans
laquelle se trouve toujours sa copine
probablement terroriser et montent la
garde jusqu'à la fin de la nuit
gabriel va évidemment choisir cette
deuxième solution le lendemain matin
après avoir très peu dormi gabriel veux
donc essayer de savoir s'il y avait
vraiment quelqu'un qui était là il
retourne donc à l'endroit d'où
provenaient les bruits et ils tombent
sur des traces de bottes
il précise d'ailleurs qu'il n'a pas dit
à sa copine qu'il était tombé sur des
empreintes de bottes parce qu'il voulait
pas qu elle flippe le clasico non mais
je tenais pas dit pour te protéger mais
il faut lui dire vous êtes de la vivre
cette situation voyons à ce stade de la
randonnée y reste et gabriel et sa
copine environ
deux jours de marche avant d'arriver au
bout du parcours bien entendu suite à
cet évènement ils vont marcher beaucoup
plus vite la journée pour couvrir le
plus de terrain possible mais c'est
quand même pas des surhommes ils vont
pas réussir à faire deux jours de
randonnée en un jour et donc ils vont
devoir passer une nouvelle et dernière
nuit dans la forêt gabriel explique
qu'il a trouvé un endroit près d'une
falaise dans un petit surplomb dans
lequel il serait cool de monter leur
tente puisque du coup les gens ne
pourrait venir que d'eux devant eux et
pas de 360 degrés autour d'eux bref ils
ont installé le camp dans ce petit
surplomb ils ont préparé leur nourriture
ils sont glissées dans leur sac de
couchage dans la tente
après quelques minutes sa copine s'est
endormi et lui il est resté éveillé
pendant quelques heures en écoutant les
bruits des bois aux alentours et en
essayant de voir si quelqu'un allait de
nouveau venir autour de leur camp au
bout d'un moment gabriel et ans exténué
vu qu'il a déjà très peu dormi la nuit
d'avant ils s'en mordent il va se
réveiller plus tard dans la nuit à cause
de ce qui semble être quelqu'un une
nouvelle fois de l'autre côté de la
paroisse de la tente qui fouille dans
leurs affaires gabriel shop son arme et
grâce à ce qui reste de leurs feux de la
veille à savoir des petites breizh
il arrive à voir la silhouette de la
personne qui est vraiment à 1 m de la
tente
il décide alors de lui hurler dessus en
lui disant on est armé dégagé et voit
alors les silhouettes lâcher les
affaires et partir en courant gabriel
sort de la tente avec larmes anjou prêt
à tirer si jamais quelqu'un se montrent
menaçants c'est un [ __ ] de cowboy
gabriel qu'on soit d'accord
et malheureusement ils constatent que
leurs affaires sont éparpillés
absolument partout sur le camp les gars
qui étaient là ont tous fouillés
gabriel prend la direction des gens qui
ont pris la fuite ce qui l'amène près
d'un petit ruisseau et au loin près du
petit ruisseau y voit une lumière
scintiller une lumière qui ressemble à
tout simplement une lanterne qui
clignotent et après quelques secondes il
voit trois autres lumières qui
clignotent celle à qui comprend que la
personne en face ce n'est pas une
personne c'est un groupe de personnes et
décide alors de revenir en courant au
campement et dire à sa copine de tout
remballer aussi vite qu'elle le peut
parce qu'il doit vite se casser de là
mon gars croyez moi pour réussir à faire
des affaires at levé et a décidé de
marcher alors qu'il fait nuit noire que
tu es en pleine forêt et tu sais qu'il
ya quatre personnes pas loin de ton
campement faut avoir du méga bulls mois
dans ces situations là je fusionne avec
le sac de couchage je disparais de la
surface de la terre bref islam et ils se
remettent à marcher pour finir le
parcours et ne plus jamais entendre
parler de ces trous du cul qui rôdent
autour de leur campement
cette fois pendant qu'ils marchent
gabriel entend des voix où l'on toutes
les dix secondes il regardait à lui pour
être sûrs qu'ils sont pas suivis bref il
fait plusieurs heures de marche dans la
terreur et dans l'angoissé la plus
totale après un bon moment passé à
marcher gabriel entend un groupe
qui vient derrière et ils voient
quelqu'un qui est sortie des bois il
fait encore nuit à ce moment là c'est
tout juste l'aube et le gars restent
immobiles là debout à quelques dizaines
de mètres d'eux et les fixe pendant
quelques secondes avant de se retourner
et d'aller de nouveau dans les bois à
partir de là gabriel et sa copine
accélère fortement le pas on veut finir
ce parcours et ne plus entendre parler
de ces gens et il arrive finalement à
atteindre la fin du sentier est
l'endroit où sa copine avait garé sa
voiture à au début du parcours et ils
ont pu sortir des bois de virginie sans
recroiser la route de ces personnes là
qui ont pillé leurs affaires bref il ne
sait pas qui c'était ne sais pas ce
qu'il voulait et il explique
malheureusement que à notre plus grande
tristesse
il ne retournera pas là-bas pour obtenir
des réponses jamais un débat
on arrive donc au bout de ces trois
histoires [ __ ] c'est bon cette fois oh
là là elle était bien long mais j'adore
des mécaniques très différente bien là
dedans je suis content pour une fois il
ya une personne qui a été l' inverse
d'un parano qui a été parano d'être
parano et qui du coup n'a pas agi aka
francis hallé vous en faites pas
personnes vont ouvrir la porte de votre
maison ou passer par une porte fenêtre
et dormir sur votre canapé
c'était bien bas dans une fois de plus
je vais encore mieux faire mais mes
fenêtres moi c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dépasser une agréable soirée et
nuit
et si vous avez regardé ça en journée et
dont vous avez bien fait bien jouer à
vous et à très vite si yu
[Musique]